this is our main this is our main lab
over here these blue objects these are
part of the vibration isolation system
so this is a vacuum chamber and inside
each one of these types of chambers
lives a mirror of like oh this is very
rare for us but it turns out that the
this chamber is actually not under
vacuum right now see the door is craned
off and if you come over here you'll see
that it's actually open for work going
on inside we're trying to measure
something that's 10 to the minus 18
meters of motion and you know when I
first heard it I actually thought this
is absurd this is crazy and then I just
couldn't let go I was like okay this is
crazy enough that we've got to try to do
it and I was hooked I rabun hooked ever
since I've been hooked since 1991 when I
started this as a graduate student in
the field my name is nur kiss mawawala
and i'm a professor of physics at MIT
if you have the surface of a pond and
you poke your a rock or your finger in
ripples starting from where you're
poking the pond set out and they spread
over the surface of the pond so on
science picture of space-time is all is
similar where you have some massive
object could be a black hole or a
neutron star and the radiation the waves
from that objects leave the object and
propagate through space they travel at
the speed of light so that's what a
gravitational wave is now it turns out
that gravity is a completely unexplored
messenger it encodes information about
the structure of space-time about the
warpage of space-time in ways that light
cannot even sometimes contain so a black
hole is a very good example if there's a
black hole that sits around in space and
has nothing bright around it or no other
matter that's falling into it that can
glow we can't know about it we can't
learn much about it whereas if we could
study the gravitational waves from that
black hole we could reconstruct almost
everything about it LIGO which is the
laser interferometer gravitational-wave
Observatory is one of a handful of such
very big experiments scattered across
the planet to detect gravitational waves
so how do we then go about measuring
these waste and I imagine that my two
space-time objects were in fact a laser
and a mirror one of the effects of a
gravitational wave is that as it passes
through some region of space it shrinks
and stretches the distances between
objects in that region of space so all I
have to do is measure the travel time of
the light going out to the mirror and
coming back if a gravitational wave
passed through this region then the
distances between these two would change
and the light travel time would change
and I could register or record the
passing gravitational wave and the
principle is as simple as that now in
reality it life is not so simple because
of the weakness of gravitational way
there are extremely
paint if you will so if you take a
spacetime distance off about a metre say
so this distance facing and if a
gravitational waves game by that came
from a reasonably you know nearby
neutron star binary system it would
change that space-time distance by 10 to
the minus 21 meters that's a million
times smaller than a proton so if you
want to do this as really only two
things you need to do what you need to
do them really really well the one thing
is you need to make mirrors very still
and then there's a second thing which is
it's kind of useless to make a mirror
that's so so still if you have no way of
knowing how still it is so you also have
to have a way of measuring through those
tiny motions and that's where the laser
light comes in so we use the laser light
as our meter stick for telling us where
is this mirror relative to the laser you
can think of squeezing as making our
meter stick more precise making it a
micrometer stick or a nanometer in our
case it happens to be an atom meter
stick but okay well let's just see how
we're doing here alright Georgia Eric
and Maggie together are building a
squeezer that can go inside the vacuum
right through that door is the open
chamber that's where this is going to go
on this table is where we have the
lasers that we get our light for which
are coming over here to bring the light
and this is where the action will cavity
is where we're generating our squeezing
think of a laser having all of its noise
distributed in a ball or you know or a
circle if the noise is represented by
the radius of the circle it just says no
matter which way I look along the circle
it's the same amount of noise now when
you create a squeezed state which are
intrinsically doing is you're taking
that circle and you're squeezing it into
an ellipse
and now what you see is that along the
thin part of the lips you have smaller
less noise than your original circle did
but along the long part of the ellipse
you have more noise than your original
circle did and that's what we're
observing on the spectrum analyzer when
we look at the the shot noise level that
first line that's just the round ball it
just basically says noise is equal
anywhere you look so when we use
squeezed light we actually are arranging
the quantum fluctuations of the light so
that they are smaller along the axis
we're measuring and therefore we can
make a more precise measurement the
squeezed light source that we're
building when we can make a factor of
two improvement we think that's really
what it's doing the plan is for it to be
delivered to the LIGO observatories
sometime in the next year or two as part
of upgrades to the advanced LIGO
detectors there's a lot of excitement
that will see those last seconds to
minutes of the lifestyle of binary
neutron stars and black holes that's
exciting and it's going to be new and
never done before but really the most
exciting thing probably is that we don't
know what else is out there that we can
see using this new technique the
gravitational waves that we're searching
for they happen to be in the human audio
band so there they had just happened to
be that our set instruments are most
sensitive sort of from 10 Hertz to 10
kilohertz which is very much the human
audio bansal when we observe these
gravitational waves will be listening to
the universe so until now we have sight
we can see we haven't heard and now
we're about to turn on another sense
you
you
so I started sketching and trying to
think of how a membrane with some
proteins in it would look across two
pages and work with with the text on the
page it's really important in the
creative process all that discovery that
happens